Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors and today's presentation is on biotoxins, the word biomeads
livid and that prefix and toxins is obviously a toxin, a substance that's not good for your
body.
So, we talk about biotoxins, we're talking about livid organisms, so I separated this presentation
into two presentations so that they wouldn't be quite so long and you could choke through
them.
This is a very common issue that we deal with patients, so we're talking about livid pathogens
in a person's body.
It's a very common condition because just about everybody you could say has some sort of
parasitic infection.
Does it mean that we need to be attacking it?
Does it mean that it's causing the person a lot of symptoms, not necessarily.
It means that there's bacteria and virus that live inside your body symbiotically as
well.
So, they're living in a symbiotic relationship meeting that they are livid off of you but
they are actually helping you too, so it's not that we want to rid our body of every single
possible pathogen, it just means we want to rid our body of pathogens that are making us
sick.
So, as an example, if you swab the throat of a hundred people on the street, that none
of them have any throat condition or any sore throat or any cough or cold, a vast majority
of them are going to show positive for strep because strep is part of your normal flora,
so does it mean that we should use, everybody should get out of antibiotic and kill every pathogen
of their body?
Absolutely not.
We don't want to do that.
Because we will, that is the problem that we have right now, really, isn't it?
We've destroyed our normal flora, which are hundreds of millions of different organisms that
are keeping everything in balance, as soon as we take an antibiotic, we throw that off
balance.
Not against use of antibiotics when we need to use antibiotics, but it's what we need to
use antibiotics and then you have to help heal that flora.
So the levied organisms that we're talking about, the biotoxins that we're mainly discussing
are bacteria, virus, bald, fungus, and parasites, and we'll get through the top two.
This is just an overview, understand.
So I'm going to have further presentations on each one of the single bacteria that we're
going to talk about are single virus organisms that are so deadly and causing so many problems
as you go here.
So, initially, with just an overview of different bacterial infections, they'll understand
that all these things that we're talking about, really, bacteria is the only thing that's
really going to be really, that antibiotics are going to be effective against.
And should you take, okay, so you look at this little chart here, the top one is strep.
So should I take antibiotics if I have strep, another really other day, say, oh my gosh,
my daughter had strep and she had a such a sore throat and she was coffeeed and a mucous
seed, we brought her in, they did a culture, they gave her antibiotic.
Should you do that?
That's always the question.
Well, nobody can completely answer that question, not a doctor either.
I don't want to be the one that answers that question either.
I always like to ask a question, what a parent, what a parent asks me that question, I ask
a question back.
If a person obviously has a strep, so bad that they are, their throat is closing up, it's
just very, very sick, then using an antibiotic to duck that strep down is probably the right
way to go.
But here's a problem when you take an antibiotic, normally, remember the immune response, normally
a person is exposed to will use strep, so you're exposed to strep.
If you fire an immediate immune response, that's your TH1 response.
So your TH1 response, remember, is all your immune cells, all your killer cells, so think
of them as they are the breed core with machine guns that are going out there to try to kill
that strep.
So when they are firing and when they are attacking the strep, they are doing damage to self tissue
at that time, too.
So part of the person's sore throat is actually your own immune response, killing strep that
are there, too.
So it's not just the strep that is causing the swelling of the throat, it's really an immune
response that's causing that, which is good, that's what you want.
And then I got a sore throat, so I have this TH1 system firing here for the first 24 to
48 to 72 hours, my TH1 system is firing to kill this.
So I go in and take my child in the early sides of this, and they say, yep, she has strep,
so here we're going to give you this antibiotic, and you take the antibiotic, and if it is strep,
a bacterial strep, then it will usually kill the strep, and that's a good thing, right?
But is it?
So if I killed a bacterial infection with an antibiotic, before you were able to elicit
a TH2 response, so remember, your immediate immune response is a TH1 response.
After 24 to 72 hours, if that cannot kill the infection, it suppresses and you fire this
TH2 response, and the responsibility of the TH2 response is primarily to make antibodies
against that thing, which the TH1 response initially fired against.
So in their case of our example, would be strep.
So after about 24 to 72 hours, by TH2 response fires, and I start to make antibodies against
strep, is that a good thing or a bad thing?
That's a very good thing.
So now I'll have circulated antibodies against strep, against this specific strep, which will
react to a lot of different streps, there's hundreds of different streps, understand.
So it'll react to a lot of different streps, and so I have these circulated antibodies for
anywhere from a year to 10 years, which is, is that a good thing or a bad thing?
It's a very good thing.
So I've created an immune to T, per se, it's not going to be perfect, there's no immunity
is perfect, but if I allowed my body to go through a TH1, TH1 suppression, then TH2 reaction
and my TH2 system started making antibodies against that which my immune system initially
fired, well I am actually increasing by the health of my immune system, because now I have
circulated antibodies against that pathogen.
So the next time, three months later, I'm exposed to strep again, well I might not get any symptoms,
so why does one person, you know, two, three people go to a party and they're all three
of us are exposed to the same strep from that sick person with strep, that's pretend they're
all exposed to the exact same number of organisms, and why does only one of them get sick
or the other two don't get sick?
Well, the other two had number, what a healthy enough TH1 response to kill it off, or they
had already had circulated antibodies.
So as soon as that body was exposed to that strep, that circulated antibody tagged it and
when you did get that initial TH1 firing, it found it right away and was able to kill it.
So by not allowing your body to go through that TH1, TH2 reaction, you'll never really
strengthen your immune system.
Now, that doesn't mean that you never get it antibiotic, there are certain infections and
we'll talk about Lyme disease, I recommend that you get an antibiotic even at first thought
that you have Lyme disease, because your immune system will typically not be able to kill
that.
So if it goes to a chronic or autoimmune Lyme, we got lots of problems, but a strep is
one of the nasty ones, but if you have something at other bacterial infection, to get it antibiotic
is maybe not the right thing to do right away.
If you ride it out just a little bit longer so you can fire a TH2 reaction, and then if you
have to get a antibiotic, you can.
Well, how do I know I fired a TH2 reaction?
Well, you don't, because a person could fire a TH2 reaction within the first 24 hours
and it could take three or four days.
We just don't know that.
However, it is usually safe to ride something out with kids with infections, we're not going
to get into the whole, what should you do with each individual case, but if their fever
gets over a hundred and four, then you have to do something.
So I'm not saying that we don't want to, this is an integrative clinic, these are integrative
lessons, so we don't want to throw out modern medicine, we want to integrate it and just
try to use wisdom and everything that we're doing.
So bacteria are the only thing that are effective against antibiotics, or I should say that antibiotics
are really effective against.
There's two main classifications of bacteria, there's gram positive and gram negative bacteria
they're named, so because of how they stain with a gram stain, would you look at them
in a slide.
However, the reason why they stain that way is because there's something very different in
their cell wall.
So the cell membrane of gram negative bacteria have a, another thing in it called a lipopoly
saccharide coating.
So this lipopoly saccharide coating on a gram negative bacteria makes it, often a little
bit more of a nasty bacteria.
Lime disease, the Borrelia bacteria is a gram negative bacteria, H. Pylora is a gram negative
bacteria.
And what do we kill, Lyme disease, or H. Pylora, would you kill any gram negative bacteria, even
using an antibiotic to kill it, you liberate this lipopoly saccharide.
And I do a whole lecture on H. Pylora, and I do multiple lectures on Lyme disease, so I'm
not going to get into it too deep.
But when you kill a gram negative bacteria, you liberate this lipopoly saccharide, and it
becomes an endotoxin in the person's body as well, that you have to deal with.
And many times you have to keylate that out.
But that's for another time.
Which Pylora, you hear a lot about, with stomach ulcers, because it is the primary cause
of a stomach ulcer, used to take stomach ulcers, were caused by too much stress, and stress
caused your stomach to make more hydrochloric acid, and it was just this excess about a hydrochloric
acid that causes stomach ulcers.
Well, thank goodness we, through the modern science, has finally agreed with what we were
saying a long, many, many years ago, is that it's ridiculous, it is some sort of infection.
Well, we found out what the infection was, modern science did, a few decades back, and
what a Nobel Prize for doing so, that it was H. Pylora, H stands for Helical Bacter.
Helical Bacter Pylora is a bacterial infection, it's a gram negative bacterial infection.
That is everywhere, it's ubiquitous.
You cannot not be exposed to H. Pylora.
Now, well, why does it everybody have stomach ulcers?
Well, if you have enough stomach acid, this is the little twist of this, if you have enough
stomach acid in your stomach, and you swallow some food that has H. Pylora in it, your stomach
acid kills it, so you don't have any issues.
It's only when you have a decreased stomach acid, when you have a hypochloridria, that you
even are susceptible to H. Pylora.
Now, H. Pylora, this is a picture of H. Pylora migrating through a gastric cell into the cells
right underneath the gastric cells, the epithelial cells, and causes this infection, and it's just
a road's away and causes this whole of this person's stomach, and they bleed from it to
that stomach ulcer.
However, most of the time, but maybe upwards to 90% of the time, it does not cause a stomach
ulcer.
The H. C. L. is high enough for the pH is high enough, and the H. C. L. is low enough for
it to even live in the stomach, many times it will go right through the wall and enter the
bloodstream, and then we have really problems, because H. Pylora is one of the top five causes
of cardiovascular disease.
It is a major cause of cancer, it's the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide.
It is a major cause of many cancers, it's a bad guy, so this talks about endothelial cells
and vitro with H. Pylora and some other studies with cardiovascular disease, but I'll save
that information for when we get into a whole lecture at H. Pylora for you guys who want
to dig into that.
This talks about it via major cause of cancer, what it does is it affects the receptor sites,
so it blocks a poptonic receptor sites on the outside of the cell, and it infiltrates
the cell and can change the replication cycle, so it's a nasty little beastie, and this
is what a lot of the gram negative bacteria are, is they have the ability to enter the cell,
so most bacteria do not have the ability to enter the cell, so that's what differentiates
a big part of what differentiates, how a bacteria acts in the person's body and a virus
acts in the person's body, a virus typically will infiltrate the cell and actually will end
up killing the cell, no, it, a bacteria typically does not infiltrate the cell, but some gram
negative bacteria do, Lyme is another one of those, H. Pylora is another one, that's why
your immune system can't kill it, and that's why if you don't catch it when it's in the
blood vessel, it had a biotic one kill it, so if you have a chronic H. Pylora or a chronic
Lyme, you can't take it in a biotic because it's no longer extracellular, it's no longer
in the bloodstream, it's hiding in the different cells, so this is the Boralia, this, the bacteria
causes Lyme disease, it has, that's, it looks like a little spirochet, it goes, it hides
inside the cells. Okay, so next week we're going to talk about viruses, don't worry if you
did get your, your, your year full of the Lyme and H. Pylora because those are so prevalent
that we see in our practice, we have multiple presentations on each one of those and constantly
pull it up, do research on those and I put together a whole presentation of that research
paper for you egg heads out there that are like me that want to know this information. So
next week we're going to talk about viruses and the Lyme and, or not Lyme but the mold and
fungus and different parasites that are very common so stay with us, I hope you learned something
if this was too fast, go back and listen to it again otherwise I'll see you next week.